if you haven't seen it yet
you're gonna see it now because this is
the miami dolphins organization
with a lot of players punctuated by
their head coach brian flores with their
explanation of what they plan to do
before the game on sunday when they face
the patriots in new england here it is
is it authentic
that's the mystery or is it just another
symbolic victory now there's two anthems
do we kneel do we stand if we could just
right our wrongs we wouldn't need two
songs we'll need another publicity
parade
so we'll just stay inside until it's
time to play the game
whatever happened to the funds that were
promised all of a sudden we got a
collapsed pocket the bottom line should
not be the net profit you can't open
your heart when it's controlled by your
wallet
decals and patches fireworks and
trumpets we're not puppets don't
publicize false budgets
ask the pundits and we shouldn't have a
say
if you speak up for change then i'll
shut up and play if we remain silent
that would just be selfish since they
don't have a voice we're speaking up for
the helpless it's not enough to act like
you care for the troops millions for
pre-grade patriotism you get paid to
salute lift every voice and sing it's
just a way to save face lose the mass
and stop hiding the real game face
so if my dad was a soldier but the cops
killed my brother do i stand for one
anthem and then kneel for the other this
attempt to unify only creates more
divide so we'll skip this song and dance
and as a team we'll stay inside
we need changed hearts not just a
response to pressure enough no more
fluff and empty gestures we need owners
with influence and pockets bigger than
ours to call up officials and flex
political power
when education is not determined by
where we reside
and we have the means to purchase what
the doctor prescribed and you fight for
prison reform and innocent lives and you
repair the communities that were tossed
to the side and you admit you gained
from it and you swallowed your pride and
when greed is not the compass but love
is the guide and when the courts don't
punish skin color but punish the crime
until then we'll just skip the long
production and stay inside for centuries
we've been trying to make you aware
either you're in denial or just simply
don't really care
it's not a black white thing or a left
right thing
let's clean the whole bird and stop
arguing about which wing
before the media starts wandering and
guessing they just answered all your
questions
we'll just stay inside
powerful powerful video and the message
from the dolphins is they're not coming
out
all season long the way i read that yeah
forget it we're not going to be part of
this and the line that really resonated
with me
every one of them did to some level or
another but this attempt to unify only
creates more divide that gets to what we
were talking about it
it's hopeless at this point i am a very
hopeful and positive person i also try
to balance
you know legitimate concerns with like a
virus that is killing people uh despite
the mixed messages we've received for
months about whether or not it really is
something that should be taken seriously
but i still try to view the world as
glass half full i still try to have a
hopeful and optimistic view for the
future
but the reality is
the attempt to unify only creates more
divide because we are like we are two
nations
whose inhabitants
are living in the same
giant tract of land
and the question is can we find a way to
coexist because we're not going to
change each other's minds there are two
different americas period
and
nothing you say chris nothing i say
nothing anyone else says is going to
change it and uh it's just that's that
is our reality and the sooner we accept
it and try to figure out how to thrive
within it the better off we'll all be
yeah of course i mean that's what we're
all hoping for here and that was an
amazing video by the miami dolphins and
of course they have an amazing leader in
brian flores you know how i feel about
him mike i mean to me he's one of the
better human beings in all of football
he's something somebody i would follow
in a second i've known him for a long
time and he's a guy again that i'll say
is just he's seen all this all these
issues we have you know first hand he
came from what brownsville new york like
right in brooklyn there it's it's one of
the roughest toughest areas in our
country so he's seen it all and
yes that was a very powerful statement
and i think
you know the the the fact of staying
inside
i don't know sometimes i almost feel
like can
maybe sway some of those people who are
on the fence
to come over to what i'll call the good
side okay
a little bit more than maybe
because
the ones that kneel where those people
on the fence now they're oh they're
throwing this in my face and they're
just like chris what chris what this
this issue has been around for four
years yeah
in the past four years
have you come across a single human
being who has said to you i'm not really
sure how i feel about this
yeah i have i have yeah i haven't i
haven't ever i i get arguments with my
is some of my idiot friends and even
family members all the time where i'm
going you're going to no but yeah but no
no no no but i'm talking about somebody
who's truly undecided everybody has
their viewpoint and it's not changing
that's the thing nothing we say is going
to change anyone's mind and nothing they
say is going to change our mind and
that's what we have become however we
got here whether it's just the natural
evolution of our civilization whether
it's manipulation by russian bots and
trolls on social media yeah well that's
there whatever it may be but whatever
the explanation well we gotta be right
i'm
but we've seen some change already from
the four years to now i mean we're
seeing even just in the nfl the white
players who have stood up and started to
speak out i mean they've changed so
they've changed their behavior they
haven't changed their mind okay that's a
step in the right direction you're right
there are some out there that you can
change their mind there are i i do
believe that i've had a few friends who
yeah you know unfortunately they haven't
had the experiences i've had haven't
been around black black people
african-americans and they just never
even thought of some of the things that
when i have these conversations with
them i start to go wait you don't
understand you're not putting yourself
and and you can sway them to go
damn you know i never thought about that
or i never realized now you're right
it's very few i'm not trying to but i i
don't want to buy i you know maybe it's
just me being a selfish stupid american
i don't know i don't want to buy that
you can't change people i know there's a
lot you can but i think there's some we
can still
here's the hope and then we got to take
a break the hope is this the hope is
that
the extent to which the two americas are
currently at odds
is bad enough
not so bad that it ends the country but
it's bad enough that the younger
generation is disgusted by the way we're
acting and the way we can't find a way
as adults to work together and come
together oh yeah find common threads and
that they're so disgusted by it they
resolve to never do it that's our only
hope over the long hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports